an actor Orlando Bloom got his big break
playing the elf Legolas in the
box-office hit the Lord of the Rings
trilogy now he returns to fantasy and
Amazon's new series carnival row with
actress Cara Delevingne takes place in a
Victorian world where humans and
mythical creatures live together bloom
stars is a detective investigating a
serial killer Cara Delevingne plays a
fairy from his past who knows his
darkest secrets
I know you know better what do you care
give it to me no without that's why I
got the rest you just think of all the
things I could tell them
you don't know do they they don't know
the truth about you are you threatening
me maybe or maybe it's where is he you
know you never tell
you already will not take that chance
Orlando Bloom is with us good morning
you're just saying it's very it's dark
it's heavy but it takes you back to
where we all remember you from in the
beginning this idea of fantasy and Lord
of the Rings when attracts you to this
type of movie or role or series that I
read this script and obviously as you
say along the Rings was was wearing my
mice thought I really felt whilst this
was a fantasy I never heard anything
like it I never seen a world like it
there's a wonderful kind of theme
running through the story we kind of
look at there there's a social
commentary on the refugee migrant crisis
there's a it's a I played a detective
who's investigating the murder of a face
show girl in carnival where the Fae who
are our kind of they really represent
the migrants and refugees and kora
players of Harry and there are parks and
all kind of mythical creatures and they
represent these refugees and migrants
who had really coming to the burg which
is all intensive purposes like our
London yeah and looking for sort of a
safe place and they get sequestered into
carnival row and their lives play out
there and and so yeah it's a it's a sort
of dark interesting war thriller drama
but there's also this sort of beautiful
love story between myself and Cara and
and it's nice to be able to be a part of
something that comments a little bit on
what's going on in the world yeah yeah
it's your first TV starring role it is
in a TV series yeah it is a different
work in anyway you know honestly the way
that they're making TV today it really
isn't yeah I mean the sets were
phenomenal the biggest we were a shot in
Prague the location was fantastic but
they had a back lot and and it was just
so detailed and vivid and real and as an
actor that's what you want you want a
great stage so you can you can give a
performance on the front of a green
screen you know they really spared no
expense and and and so it doesn't I
think I think there's sort of been that
it sort of felt a little bit like TV was
like a little brother to movies at some
point and I think that's kind of with
the way people stream and can consume
content these days you know we're on
Amazon Prime now as you know and it's
like you can stream eight hours and it
felt like an eight hour
really like a big movie now you said
that this character that you play is
very dark and he has secrets and we see
that in the first episode that there's
something he's not willing to share just
yet
how do you relate to this character when
you think about someone who has these
secrets or how much do we all sort of
relate to someone who doesn't want to
share whatever it is that's that's
bothering them and not allowing them to
be vulnerable yeah I mean look I think
with Philo he's an interesting man he
was institutionalized his whole life so
he was born in an orphanage and then
raised in to the on into the Army and
then he becomes a detective you know
this secret he has I sort of like and as
it evolves you'll see when you I don't
want to give too I can't give it away
obviously no spoilers but for me it was
like his superpower okay because it
enables him to become this empathetic
being and to have a certain sense of
empathy and compassion for that for the
plight of the faith Oh which i think is
so such a wonderful thing to be able to
do in a in a show can I take you a
little bit off the show because we have
to mention Katy Perry here yeah your
fiance the two of you have such an
amazing relationship that a lot of
people see play out a little bit respect
for each other support of each other but
recently you were on a show she called
in she did to see you didn't was
supposed to be impersonating your fiance
and and you didn't know it was her have
you taken a little bit of heat for that
[Music]
the taste of her cherry chapstick yeah
it was great not convinced with that
really got thrown under a bus I will say
that that she is incredibly good at
doing a faux English accent your thank
you but so I was really frightened yeah
I was like but she's you know that
it's not the show your showrunner
suggested she might come on the show as
in the cameo have you talked to her
about that she would be fantastic she
could be amazing fairy but alright
Orlando thanks so much
anyway this Carnival Row is streaming
now on Amazon Prime video